hey 42 here everyone has that weird
friend who is completely obsessed with
horror films and the McCobb and if you
don't have a friend like that then it's
probably you but one has to ask why why
do some people enjoy being scared whilst
others don't I mean it's not as if our
bodies are designed to enjoy it quite
the opposite
fear is a chemical response in your
brain to the potential for harm it's not
the thing that will actually harm us
that creates a fear response is to lead
up to the event so if you hear smashing
glass during the night the sound alone
isn't going to harm you but nonetheless
your brain starts to produce a cocktail
of chemicals and you feel scared so it
has to be asked who the hell enjoys
feeling like they are about to come to
harm to try and understand this oddity
of human behavior in 1994 free
psychologists showed a bunch of college
students free documentary videos the
first showed cows being killed and
butchered in an abattoir the second clip
depicted a live monkey being struck in
the head with a hammer having its skull
cracked open and its brain served as a
dessert and the last clip showed a
child's facial skin being turned inside
out in preparation for surgery it makes
me nauseous just saying that stuff so
it's not surprising that 90% of the
students in the study turned the videos
off before reaching the end and everyone
in the study said that they found the
imagery deeply disturbing yet these same
individuals will gladly pay actual money
to see much gory and horrific stuff
being shown at the cinema the
psychologists running the experiments
came up with the conclusion that it's
the unrealism of horror movies that
makes them different the vast majority
of people who watch horror are aware
that the action on screen isn't real and
this puts a psychological distance
between the viewer and the traumatic
events unfolding on-screen and if you do
believe that what you see in horror
films is real then you're a psychopath
and you probably shouldn't be allowed
outside after
in fact evidence shows that younger
viewers of horror films are more
negatively affected because they are
more likely to believe in the film's
realism but according to research
published by doctor Deirdre Johnston not
every horror fun is the same there are
essentially two different types of
people who enjoy feeling scared the
first are gore seekers
these people usually have low empathy
levels and seek out sensational content
the research also noted that gore
seekers tend to identify strongly with
the killer in a movie so yeah that's
disturbing if your partner happens to be
a huge fan of gore movies you should
probably start sleeping with one eye
open the second kind of horror fan are
individuals with high empathy levels and
therefore identify themselves more with
the victim in the film these people
enjoy the suspense of the film and
therefore tend to watch more thrillers
rather than gore or maybe there's little
more to it than the fact that we enjoy a
thrill watching someone being chased
down the street in their pajamas by an
axe wielding maniac is in
edge-of-your-seat thrill ride will she
get away
won't she if she's wearing slippers then
probably not it's the same reason some
people enjoy rollercoaster rides it
takes us out of our comfort zone a blood
pumping break from the monotonous
normality of everyday life in fact
statistics show a correlation between
thrill seekers who enjoy rollercoasters
and crazy things like bungee jumping to
those who enjoy a good horror flick they
tend to be the same people or maybe the
most depressing conclusion of all is
that we're all psychopaths at heart
statistics show that the worst night of
the year for misbehaving children of all
ages is you guessed it Halloween
Halloween is officially the most
dangerous day of the year for children
mostly because the number of children
hit by cars increases by 300% but also
because something strange happens to
children and teenagers on Halloween
antisocial
Avia Rises significantly and maybe
that's because we all secretly empathize
with the killer at least a little thanks
for watching but there's a man equally
as despicable as Adolf Hitler yet very
few people even know of his existence
the humble caterpillar is one of the
most mined shatteringly incredulous
creatures on planet Earth